Hi.
I'm back again.
Just wanted to stress the importance
of the material you're about to learn.
Using a data structure that
employs a hash function,
allows you to do look-ups
in constant time.
Let that sink in for a second.
With everything you've learned so far,
you need to do look-ups in linear time.
In a list or a set,
you need to look through every element
to find the one you're looking for.
Stacks and cues let you look up the
oldest, or newest elements, immediately.
And priority queues will let you find
the highest priority element quickly,
but if you want any other element,
you've got to do a linear time search.
The ability to do
constant time look-ups,
will make almost any algorithm
you write, instantly faster.
Everyone here at Udacity
was really excited,
that you'd be learning such
a crucial topic today.
They all wanted to be
here to talk about it.
But they couldn't all
abandon their work, so
they decided to send a representative,
whoever was the most excited.
Let's see who they sent.
Starbucks says that this concept shows
up constantly in technical interviews.
You can almost always optimize an
answer, or improve an answer with it, or
reduce a complex question,
to just use a hash function.
Also, he saw a squirrel this morning.